okay so today I have the the chance to
be with Luca llama yellow which is a I
think a rather well-known polyglot here
on YouTube it's a great pleasure to be
with you here today
Luca first of all thank you so much for
giving me some of your precious time to
allow me to interview you today
looklive hurts mine Sam
he speaks around 12 languages right
languages and he is currently studying
interpretation in Paris so today I'm
going to be asking Luca a couple of
fishes that I think a lot of language
learners out there have in regards to
you know acquiring a foreign language
and you know how does he do it how does
he do it so well and how does he keep
his motivation and so on so are you
ready to start I'm ready to start okay
so my first question which is rather
broad is how do you go about learning a
language from scratch you know let's say
from tomorrow you were to start learning
Arabic for example what material would
you use books or else how would you get
started and for somebody who is looking
into learning a new language what kind
of advice would you give them just don't
know where to start okay so the very
first thing that I do is to get hold of
a language Sears I really like there's a
lot of language interesting and valuable
language Sears on the market I often go
for a simal which is I think I like what
I consider a brilliant language Sears
and I and I start using that that book
my advice is that you know there's a lot
of resources out there especially after
you know in this internet era so there's
a lot you can actually choose you can
select you can use but I normally advise
people I suggest that you use just one
language Sears Matt to max that you
really like for example I say I
and normally choose a Simone because it
not only adapts to the way I learn
languages but also because they like you
know the visual aspect of of that book I
think that you know using something you
like even even visually is very
important in general but I believe in
quality and I think that a salon in
general is a quality book what I do is
that I choose one language serious as I
said and then I use apply my learning
technique to it which is very precise
technique I use it back and forth
translation that is I the good thing of
a simal is that it has bilingual text so
I can use what I call the the the my
mother tongue l1 as a crutch to
understand and decipher l2 which is on
which is the language and learning and
then I first analyzed the adult d l2 and
then I do this kind of translation
towards the language I'm learning and
this is not it's not only importance you
know what you do is important but it
also depends that the time schedule is
also very important another thing that I
really think is important is to work a
little bit every day so a lot of people
for example think that I study a spend
like five or six hours on on hitting the
books but I just been 30 to four minutes
so in small chunks applying this
technique to the language tears yes I
you know I I believe in the so called
language path everybody can choose a
different language path
there's people spend a lot of time you
know on the language of the beginning
like and I know five hours four to five
hours for example there is intensive
courses they go to school and they go to
a school and they spend a lot of time on
language but the thing is that as an
independent language learning
there was nobody telling me
what I should do so I just decided to
spend a little bit 30 minutes a day well
not only I would say they you know
sometimes it happens that I also spend a
couple hours sorry 30 minutes in the
morning and maybe 30 minutes in the
afternoon what I believe is important
and also writing in a book which
confirmed my belief is that learning in
chunks is better if you spend four hours
well if you have the mental stamina have
to do that I'll go for it but the thing
is as far as I'm concerned even if it
might sound a little bit weird cuz I'm
very passionate about language learning
I do think that spending a little amount
of time at something helps you
concentrate him focus on what you do
much more so I believe in planning
quality first and quantity later well
yeah English French Spanish and German
no I just learned English at school if
you can call it learning because it
didn't learn much at school French I
learned in school and most ago watching
television and then as as far as German
and Spanish were concerned I used
another language Sears because I hadn't
found out the I hadn't you know figured
out that it was such a brilliant
language Sears is a symbol and then from
from the other language I learned was
the first language I learned with asthma
was Dutch and from then on I just used a
simal every time I had to start learning
a language for every single language I
learned so basically if we were to sum
up your your advice here that would be
to focus on one or two at the most
language resources at the beginning and
learn in chunks at the beginning of
you know what the beginner stages yes
and learn and learn everyday I want to
emphasize the fact that you know it's a
as I said it's a personal choice you can
spend a lot of time in on you can invest
a lot of time in the language but the
main problem is that a lot of people are
not willing to invest that time a lesser
are constantly stimulated for example if
they go to schools to a language school
so the problem is that they won the risk
of burning out one problem that I life
is pretty big is that there's a lot of
people trying to tackle three four or
five languages at the same time
investing a lot of time and and you know
they're run a risk they seriously run
the risk of burning out and giving up
because that's that's I think that the
beginning of the path the first part of
the path is kind of delicate is the most
complicated because it's easy to give up
like when you start working out and you
start jogging at the beginning you find
it very difficult because you're not
basically you're not used to it
but once you get going gets easier so at
the beginning you have to do a little
bit and then move on so that's that's
what I well you know you can always
learn a lot of languages at the same
time and you have to you know the more
languages you learned the more
complicated it gets to organize your
time schedule you have to put more
effort into it
so yeah basically it would be better to
learn one language at a time but it you
know if you want to do it when I go for
a lot of languages please do as long as
you you know you can exactly great
second question here is something I've
been wondering about for a couple of
weeks or a couple of months it's the
issue of setting goals you know a lot of
people say that without goals it's just
kind of like just going blindly into
learning something and that goals it you
know it's something that is very very
important and I
like to know your opinion about that how
important do you think setting goals is
in language I think that setting goals
is plays a huge role in language
learning because if your goals are vague
that you don't know where you're going
well if you know we're going if you if
you have an objective you know exactly
where it going if you already learn the
language you know that you have to go
through a lot of phases I basically
divided the whole language learning
process you never end actually you never
ends learning but in general there's
like three stages like the beginning
phase the intermediate and then the
advanced so if you have if you kind of
if you have a general picture it might
help you to figure out what you have to
do and what goals you want to accomplish
and to reach in a certain amount of time
so for example if you're a beginner and
you want to reach intermediate an
intermediate phase or intermediate
stadium stage whatever you want to call
it what you should do is for example
tell yourself now I'm going to use the
first language tiers then once you have
finished this the the first book you can
add something else and when you another
thing that is very important is people
ask me when Dwight when do I figure out
where I am am i intermediate am i a
beginner I think that you figure out
that for example you were passed the the
the beginner phase when the same content
that you've been using for a lot for
like three months four months gets
boring it gets too easy so when
something gets to easier it gets boring
it's time to move on it's time to do
something else I also emphasize the fact
that I always emphasize the fact that
you know there in your work is very
important there's a lot of people say I
abide by this kind of learning I really
like for example listening and reading
and that's absolutely fantastic because
the input input is important to language
learning but what I do Joe is to I try
to vary my work so that I work in all
areas of the language like listening a
reading is very important it's a
condition DCO scenic when I'm that's a
necessary but not sufficient condition
as far as I'm concerned because they
like playing with the language in the
very beginning so I like activating some
arizim of brain even if I this doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to speak
you have to talking as native speakers
get out there and talk and it means that
you can do something else you have other
techniques to develop what you're
learning so input you transform it you
can I do this by translating that you
can talk to yourself for example you can
do other exercise you can read out loud
so there your work is very important so
a game back to what I was saying before
it's having goals short term and long
term goals is very important if you
already learned a language you probably
know what these goals are if you've
never learned a language you can
actually establish kind of boundaries
for example you can tell yourself well I
in the beginning phase I'm going to use
just one book maybe two if you like and
having other material materials and once
you finish the book you're going to do
something else you're going to tie
yourself the phase one is over and you
may coincide with with the asmol series
or whatever teach yourself whatever
colloquial and then you move on I mean
say you're going to change your strategy
having the same strategy all over the
process of language learning is not a
good thing so you have to change things
because things get boring over time you
know as you said at the beginning stages
you focus on one or two resources and
once you hit that intermediate stage you
told me that then you start to vary the
kind of material you're dealing with is
that right yes that's absolutely that's
absolutely right the main difference is
that the level of autonomy that you have
when you start learning language not
very high it means that you have to rely
on books that explain thanks to you
well when you get taught when when you
enter the the so called intermediate
phase you are a little bit more
dependent independent and you can learn
what to you can choose the material you
know the difference is that the Internet
makes it possible to go out there and to
get hold of a lot of a lot of
interesting resources if you have like
some taste you have certain interests
the Internet allows you to
choose to go there and then say look I
like geography I like history wants you
you know learn about anything any any
any topic and that's great because when
you were interested in something you
your desire to understand what you're
reading what you're listening is very
Hans so you will put more effort and
more enthusiasm into you know language
learning and acquiring the content that
you are exposed to so that that's you're
being exposed to so that's that's a big
difference that means that at the
beginning you're reading you working to
material that imposes content on you on
your tastes well in the intermediate
phase you impose you decide what you
want to learn and that makes a huge
difference and the internet makes it
possible to choose whatever you want if
you can look for it and if you know how
to find it and you can start to actually
you know learn the language through
material that is geared towards native
speakers you know for example news or
blogs that type of stuff
exactly and the most amazing thing is
that you can create your own material
for example in many languages the
example of Chinese comes to mind there's
an amazing site which is called Mandarin
spot you can actually choose you can
select a text in Chinese you can put it
into Mandarin spot in it
it gives you the whole pingyang and it
gives you all the words all the
dictionary automatically you can print
it so that changes things so you can go
to a website select an article that you
like put it in Mandarin spot and create
a version that explains everything to
you and as you know we can only learn
what we can understand so we made sure
not only can we can create material that
the that we like but we can also
understand it thanks to these tools that
you know the example of Chinese comes to
mind there's other examples like in
Russian or any other language you can
put in a Google Translate some languages
you know the case of Japanese that's
very difficult to understand the
translation because the syntax is
completely different and I I suppose
that that's the same thing for Korean
core for long languages like Spanish
Italian English Spanish English Italian
so your
in languages that have a similar
structure that makes it very easy to
create a rough translation having
bilingual taxes very useful to have a
reference it doesn't have to be precise
but it gives you general idea with a
sentence well the sentence means and
working in sentences in in messages so
you see the same message transmitted in
two languages helps you a lot to
understand the text of the language
you're learning right so basically just
to sum it all up goals are really
important they are crucial to success
right absolutely